welcome all of you to my first episode
of tactics and blunders where we are
going to review the current latest game
from a super Grand Master and find out
the amazing tactical shots as well as
blunders happen in the game
I have set up the board from the black
side and you are in the shoes of Magnus
Carlson now before we move on in case if
you are wondering of opening mode or
don't worry I have put the whole game in
the description so you can check it out
this game has three tactical phases and
you are going to see one of them right
now as in this position go case continue
with Queen to C2 which looks very
logical not only you are hitting the
weak E4 Pawn but you are eyeing up this
juicy C7 Square
but why engine give this a question mark
well Carlson answered this in the game
but bigger picture is can you find the
answer right now
please pause the video and try to find
the sequence which Carlson played in the
game
are you ready let's start so Carson
first played at six attacking the bishop
well first question comes into my mind
is why can't white play the move Rook C7
and attack the queen
and indeed this is a bad move as black
has a nice tactical shot here and that
is Rook to see a just look at this move
guys so you are pinning down this route
and now two of the white pieces are
hanging so white response is almost
forced he has to take on B7 and after
Rook takes C2 when the bishop moves
somewhere
black has a very simple move E3 where he
has multiple threads number one very
important is Bishop D5 hitting two major
guys and meanwhile black can also pick
up some pawns all in all if you look at
the engine Evolution here it says black
is completely dominating the game
so that is the reason why you cannot
just play Rook to C7 at this point
well gooks rightly continue with Bishop
to H4
and Carlson simply play E3 with the same
idea that if you play Rook to C7 I am
going to play Rook to C8 and the
resulting positions are favorable to the
black
okay in the game Gucci says maybe you
are the actual champion I don't care I
am here to attack you and that's why
Queen to G6 looks scary
pinning down the bishop also hitting the
Livescore Bishop so Carlson calmly
support the bishop with Queen to D7 and
after that white display rooked to C1
again the threat is Rook to C7 but as
you can see it has been given a question
mark and the reason is very obvious did
you spot it I'm sure you did as black
can now simply
destroy the defender of the deep on with
Bishop captures B3 boom
hahaha
what to move and the whole point is
after Pawn takes you take the spawn
and now not only you are threatening a
discover check but the e-pawn is a goner
in the long run
well Cooke says I don't care about my
material you can have it I'm going for
your king with Rook to C7
whereupon we have reached to the second
important Junction of the game where you
have to deliver the goods with the right
move
are you ready
did you find this nice move Rook to E8
wow
and the point is why can't now take on
E7
why well here is the answer if we take
on E7 with either of the piece then
blackened simply take it and after Rook
takes E7 did you see black and Checkmate
white in three moves
and yes I'm sure it's very easy e to
check all the squares are blocked so
King has to go in the corner and then
this lovely chat which finish up the
game on the spot
see how tactical Mr Carlson is playing
in this game and rightly so here Gucci's
hasn't captured on E7 but choose a very
passive move
Bishop to E1 again a question mark by
engine because not only it's a passive
move but it allows black to munch yet
another pawn and that is quintix E5
well look at this Carlson is having so
much great time as
black is having so many Pawns maybe
gukas is wondering well I'm not getting
any attack I should get my material back
and that's why he choose the move Rook
captures A7
and if you know the Carlson very well
you can easily find the next move
here Queen trade Waters so that if you
exchange the queen
the end game master will literally toy
with you for a long time
so even though it's an inaccurate Choice
suggested by engine in terms of
practical point of view this is a great
move
can in fact gookers rightly fall into
the Trap as he continue with a super
blunder
Queen captures B6 which turn out is too
much for the word as black attack just
crashed through with F3 and after Pawn
takes and queen takes
they are fun the juicy Square cannot be
defended
well he tried the McQueen E6 King at
seven and if you think that Queen A6
cover this I'm afraid it's not as black
can play E2 and bye bye Mr King so
that's why in the game this doesn't
happen and in final few moves good case
really get confused and play the
decisive blunder of the game that is S3
after that Carlson finished him like a
champ
can you do it too
well I hope you get the third critical
position right and indeed this sequence
forced the case to resign the game after
Queen check King 27 Queen to e to check
King to G3 Rook F3 check King 2 H4 and
now simple move Bishop F6 where even
though white can sacrifice the queen yet
there is a mate in seven conformed by
chess engine
so what a wonderful game by Magnus
Carlsen generally we see him the end
game expertise but here he shows why he
is on the top of the tree for such a
long time
well I hope you enjoy the video please
feel free to like subscribe and comment
on this video
and I will see you in my next episode
very soon
bye and take care